Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So today I want to tell you an amazing story
about a monkey who was hanged for treason
and then many years later in a roundabout
way kind of became the leader of the people
who had executed him.
But first I have to tell you how I learned
this story.
So Hank, as you know Nerdfighteria and I sponsor
a fourth tier fan-owned English soccer club
called AFC Wimbledon.
We're the back of shorts sponsor; our logo
occupies that liminal space between buttock
and thigh.
And not to brag or anything, but AFC Wimbledon
have won three straight games, including most
recently a two-nil defeat of Hartlepool.
So I was reading up on the game and I came
across an odd headline, Hank: Don's Down Monkey
Hangers.
This lead me to Wikipedia and you know, Hank,
usually when you fall down a Wikipedia rabbit
hole, nothing good comes from it, but occasionally,
monkey hangers!
So, Hank, journey back with me, if you will,
to the early 19th century.
The French Revolution which promised democracy
and freedom and equality has failed spectacularly,
as revolutions often do.
And in the end, all they've done is replace
a despot named Louis with a despot named Napoleon.
To celebrate his success within France, Napoleon
Bonaparte decides to start a 13 year long
conflict, aptly known as the Napoleonic Wars,
in which he conquers and then eventually loses
most of Europe, except, of course, he never
conquers Great Britain and he also never conquers
Russia because you cannot invade Russia in
the winter unless you're the Mongols.
So OK, the story goes, and sadly it is probably
just a story, that during the Napoleonic Wars,
a French warship sank just off the coast of
Hartlepool, which I should mention, I guess,
is a city in the north-east of England.
Of course like a lot of British place names
- Sunderland, Snodland, Braintree - Hartlepool
sounds like a place where hobbits live but
in fact is a real city of, like, 93,000 citizens.
Right, so this French warship sinks right
off the coast and the only survivor of the
wreck is a monkey wearing a French Army uniform.
Now the good people of Hartlepool, living
as they do in the far north-east of England,
have never seen either a French person or
a monkey so they naturally assume that this
monkey is a French spy.
An impromptu trial is held on the beach, the
monkey is found guilty of treason and hanged.
Now what probably actually happened is that
an old folk song was adapted to history but
whatever!
The people of Hartlepool have embraced this
monkey hanging business unreservedly!
In fact, Hank, since 1999 the mascot of Hartlepool's
football team has been a monkey named H'Angus.
Get it, Angus is a name and then H'Angus is
a pun on monkey hanging.
But it gets weirder.
In 2002 the guy inside the H'Angus the monkey
costume was named Stuart Drummond and mostly
as a publicity stunt the team supported Stuart
Drummond's run for mayor.
The only campaign promise he ever made was
"free bananas for all schoolchildren".
There were also lots of real politicians running:
Labour, Conservative, all the standard UK
parties, but Stuart H'Angus the monkey won!
And then, despite never getting those bananas
to school children, he was elected again in
2005 and again in 2009!
To summarize, Hank, a city in England hung
a monkey who became a mascot who became the
mayor.
I guess there are really two lessons in this
for me, Hank.
The first is embrace your history even if
it's bananas.
Ha, I made a pun.
And the second lesson for me is that we are
always in the middle of history.
Like, Hank, imagine that you're that monkey,
things could not really have gone worse.
You're conscripted into the French Army, you're
sent to sea which is not the ideal place for
monkeys to be, you're forced to wear this
ridiculous French Army outfit, and then to
top it all off you're hung by a bunch of Hartlepudlians.
If you're that monkey you're probably thinking
"Puh, this is about as bad as it could have
gone."
But there was this whole future the monkey
couldn't possibly have known about as indeed
there is a future that all of us can't possibly
know about.
And in that future this monkey becomes a weird
symbol of the community that hanged him and
then gets its ass kicked by AFC Wimbledon.
So I guess it is kind of a sad story now that
I think about it.
But we are in the middle of history and there's
something encouraging about that to me.
I mean, maybe we could make things better
for that monkey, probably not at this point
but, you know, I don't know.
I remain weirdly optimistic.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.